on a eu le grand débat et bave peut-être
qu'on ne fera que le gérald darmanin
viennent sur ce plateau qu'on fasse une
grande consultation qui veut quand il
veut
je viendrai avec grand plaisir et qu'on
fasse une consultation policiers
population professionnels de la justice
élus et construit c'est qu'on se dit sur
les trente dernières années
pourquoi aujourd'hui on est monté à un
tel niveau de sécurité au caire
alors moi je pense qu'on n'a pas vous
pas qu on vivre dans la peur faut pas
qu'on cède à la peur et on appréhende
les rues comme étant des obstacles sur
notre voie là sur notre chemin sur notre
manière de déambuler donc c'est pour ça
que je dis non il ne faut pas avoir peur
il faut évidemment tenir compte de ce
qui se passe et je suis très sensible à
ce que vous avez vécu parce que y'a
leurs ados raconté loi et je voyais à
quelques quelques quelques semaines
gérard collomb marcher dans la rue j'ai
été aussi menacé par un homme et j'ai dû
me réfugier dans l'est ce qui s'est
passé a raconté en fait qu'un homme qui
me suit qui a commencé à me demander mon
nom
numéro téléphone et j'ai refusé de le
faire quand il m'a menacé de m'agresser
et j'ai dû me réfugier dans une boutique
il a attendu dehors en fait en me disant
toutes les façons j'ai pas d'endroit où
dormir non si je suis en garde à vue
aucun problème effectivement j'ai eu
peur je veux dire dehors et c'est vrai
mais c'est au mieux la journée il était
13h donc j'étais pas je n'étais pas à
l'aise
toutefois moi je veux pas céder je veux
pas céder à ça je veux pas que la rue ne
m'appartiennent plus parce qu'un homme a
décidé que je devais lui donner mon
numéro de téléphone ça c'était déjà
arrivé avant s'est pas à ce niveau là je
pense qu'il ya énormément de tensions en
ce moment c'est ça ce que je crois c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de tensions mais ce
que je déplore c'est que les
personnalités politiques utilisent cette
tension utilisent cette peur pour une
certaine manière à ces mots les termes
comme en sauvagement qu'ils font que
jeter de l'huile sur le feu sont pas
sans apporter des solutions concrètes je
trouve que c'est un problème et je pense
que au lieu d'apporter des réponses
concrètes
en fait ils ne font que donner de grain
à moudre pour compte pour qu'on débatte
pour qu'on débatte source ce type double
cabine est urgent que ce qu'il voyait
il ne le voyais pas aussi ils subissent
ne subissait pas si ce n'est la presse
me permets de 106 en dribbles sont
immuables et la sorte que la question du
sentiment d'insécurité je pense que
c'est un mot qui est juste parce que je
crois aussi qu'on est dans une ère de
surinformation joie des images
auxquelles on assiste
on n'aurait jamais vu auparavant ok
qu'est ce que disait bruno pomart de
leur disait il y avait des choses qui se
passaient mais les réseaux sociaux
seulement ont mis en exergue des choses
qu'on voyait pas avant je pense qu il
est policier qu'il est plus à même de
nous dire que des choses atroces se
passait auparavant mais on n'avait pas
la technologie que ça à toulouse six et
donc tout le monde a peur mais parce que
aussi on voit des choses qu'on ne
pouvait pas morts par la brawn au vent